Claire is busy with work this year, so I'm
taking over the Halloween duties.
My theme is Awesomeland.
Which includes anything Phil finds awesome.
It's a pretty big umbrella.
Ooh, big, pretty umbrellas.
Those are awesome.
Claire loves blood and guts and gore.
But who says Halloween has to be scary?
Everybody but
you. This is killing her.
Something's dying.
I don't get it. What's scary about a giant
cupcake?
We're not doing scary this year.
All right, well. Heads up.
We're doing crap your pants scary on account
of the contest. So I just hope we don't
offend you over here in Candyland.
What contest?
Oh, it's something we started in the old
neighborhood. If you're into it, you, uh,
chip in 20 bucks and scariest house on the
street wins the pot.
Mm, not actual pot.
I'd have to see a prescription for that.
Wait. You're not? No.
For the 12th time, I'm not a cop.
Well, you're not going to offend me with
your little decorations.
Please know that this is Phil.
When I'm in charge. It's terrifying.
Oh, I'll bet you give all the other soccer
moms a good scare with that pin that says
boo!
You are so lucky that I have to go to work
today. Or I would show you scary.
I would win your little contest.
You don't know what you're up against.
We don't let preggos or people with heart
trouble past our front gate.
A couple of years ago, we scared a man into
the hospital almost to death.
Well, since you got an excuse, Princess,
looks like my winning streak will carry on.
Might even win at the old house too.
We left that place pretty scary.
I'm meeting a friend for coffee.
No you're not.
No. You're helping me take this all down.
Everything goes.
Everything except the bunny.
I have plans for the bunny.
You really think it's appropriate to be
strapping your teenage daughter to a gurney?
If we win, it is.
I may have to take a pee break soon.
Oh, here, use this bedpan.
I'm kidding. That's gross.
I put candy in it here.
Luke. Luke, I think I fell asleep.
This thing is like a Temple Grandin hug.
Haley, sweetie.
Gowns on backwards.
Oh, no. It's cuter this way.
Sexy people go crazy to, you know, read a
people magazine, huh?
Phil, you're not even going to try on your
doctor costume.
Nope. But we're going to win.
Does that make you happy?
Do I look happy?
You got a problem, lady?
This obsessive need to be dark and scary.
You can't even stop yourself.
I can stop whenever I want.
Well, I'm not getting sucked in.
I'm having the Halloween that I wanted.
What is all this?
Is this supposed to be funny?
No, it's supposed to be scary.
No, it's supposed to be awesome.
You know, I
could tell that you guys didn't love us
moving in next door.
Maybe because Ronnie deals pot, or maybe
because of my Confederate flag bikini.
I don't know, but. But I thought we were
becoming friends.
I was going to propose a joint Thanksgiving,
but this is really low.
No, honey. It's okay.
No, it's not okay, Ronnie.
It's rude and it's cruel.
I wish we had our old house so we could
drive it away as far as possible.
Oh my goodness.
What was that?
Uh, Amber gets touchy about this stuff.
She. She spent six months in a cuckoo farm
in Nevada. I'm sorry.
She gets mad when I say that it was in Utah.
Oh my God.
We had no idea, I swear.
It's cool. I'll just give her a box of Cap'n
Crunch and set her in front of the fish
tank. That seems to calm her down.
Okay.
We have to shut it down, we got to shut it
down.
Now, when she said joint Thanksgiving, do you
think that she meant.
No. Okay.
I know it's not the point, but we totally
would have won.
I want to leave that out of your apology.
Howdy, howdy. Ronnie.
What's up?
Ronnie. Hi.
I was looking for Amber.
Oh.
She's inside. No!
Knock it off. Amber.
Amber! Hi. Listen, I wanted to apologize.
I had no idea about your history, and I was
being insensitive, so I was hoping we could
start over.
Wow, that's really sweet.
Almost makes me feel bad for making the
whole thing up.
What trick?
She never been to a nut house?
No.
Yeah. Ain't crazy.
I mean, I've been to rehab a few times, but
that was just for paid vacation.
You lied just to make me feel bad.
No, no, we lied so that we could win with our
zombie house of horrors.
That is so messed up.
Did you say horrors?
No, no, it.
Ain't messed up. The saying is trick or
treat. This is a trick part.
Yeah.
Our yard is full of dead whores.
You got a Santa?
Yep.
Horrors! I heard it again. Why are we not
talking about this?
There will come a day when you will pay for
this. You won't know when.
And you won't know how, but you will feel
it.
Wow. That chick is scary.
Thank you.
You have no idea.